there was a tweet that went viral from a
woman who was celebrating an abortion
she had just had
and the story looks legit to me
the woman took a picture of a cake the
cake said it's a boy and then over the y
she wrote orted
so it's aborted
and the woman wrote quote
abortion is health care and also
traumatic so if you do have one please
gather all of your closest friends after
to celebrate be around endless love and
happiness for your decision thanks to
everyone who came last night
two major problems here with what she
just said i i suspect given how sad and
desperate this this post is i actually
suspect this is real i don't think it's
a troll or a setup she says you got to
be around endless love and happiness
well
the only way you're going to get endless
love and happiness is
in the life of the world to come okay
you're only going to get that in
eternity in heaven here we live in a
finite world and in a finite world
eventually the party's over and
eventually the friends go home and
eventually the lights go out
and then what are you left with
if you are so desperate to manufacture
some artificial sense of celebration and
happiness
how long can you keep that up eventually
once the party's over what are you going
to be left with that same
nagging feeling that you were trying to
paper over with the balloons and the
streamers and the festivities and what
is that nagging feeling the nagging
feeling comes from what you say is a
traumatic event
that's my one question here lady
why is abortion traumatic
why is it traumatic
it's health care you say
it's a good thing it's something to
celebrate
so then why is it traumatic
well because it's
a difficult decision
right why is it a difficult decision
well because it's a
look it's a complex issue sure okay
you're just asking you're just making
the same statement over and over again
why is it a complex issue because
it involves a mother killing her child
that's why that's where the trauma comes
from
we're not just talking about physical
trauma
we're talking about emotional trauma
here right that's why you've got to be
around the love and the happiness and
the festivities and everyone tell you
telling you you made the right decision
even though you didn't
so if it is traumatic if you know if
you're you're
being eaten away from the inside and you
just know it's so awful that you've got
to try to manufacture some semblance of
happiness
how about we just be honest and say you
shouldn't have done it in the first
place you're you're going to be a lot
happier if you just face up to that
if you have an abortion
that doesn't mean that your life is over
and you're condemned to hell and and
you'll never have a moment of happiness
or joy again you actually do have the
prospect of happiness and joy available
to you but you've got to be honest with
yourself about what you did and you've
got to repent you have to change your
mind that's what repentance means means
changing your mind you have to turn your
mind you have to turn the way you're
thinking about it and be honest and if
you're just going to live in delusion
and denial and
and beg all of your friends to come and
pretend that this horrible horrific act
is somehow other than it is you're
you're never going to be happy again
that's always going to be eating away at
you there's an abortion activist who
just made a similar kind of post
prominent abortion activist she said
quote posted a picture of a book called
what's an abortion anyway it's a little
children's book and you've got a couple
of kids in the background her kids i
guess and she says this has been our
family's bedtime story on our vacation
this week as my niece loves this book
and reads it to her little sister every
night okay i guess it's her nieces our
family was created by abortion adoption
and parenting decisions
i love our family
and then she plugs the book
whatever else might be
true or sincere in this woman's
understanding of what happened
the one thing that i know for a fact was
a lie is that
she says our our family was created by
abortion no family is ever created by
abortion families are destroyed by
abortion that's all abortion can do
because abortion means killing
someone in your family right presumably
it's
the
mother is the one who's getting the
abortion and so the abortion is
destroying your family it's so ghoulish
i mean the post itself is saying hey
kids
hey kids read this book and be happy i
didn't kill you be happy it was only
your siblings
ghoulish and we all know it's ghoulish
and this woman knows it's foolish and
the lady doth protest too much me thinks
if
she or the cake lady if they were really
confident in their decision
if they were really secure and they felt
this really is the good thing they
wouldn't be lighting up a freaking cake
and they wouldn't be making these posts
and they wouldn't be writing books about
how great it was that they're now trying
to show to kids to convince the kids who
who obviously know better and they
wouldn't be posting it constantly all
the time i'm so good i made the right
decision i'm ready that you can you can
read them gritting their teeth in the
posts
because they know
it's
wrong it's not you
the guilt that you feel for this
is not coming from me i suspect neither
of these ladies watch my show or listen
to my show or listen to many other
conservatives i suspect they've probably
ensconced themselves in as much of a
bubble as they possibly can
ideologically and i bet they just invite
all of their pro-abortion friends to
constantly affirm them in their bad
decision and yet they still know it's
wrong they are still wracked by this
nagging guilt that is called your
conscience
and you are not oh man you are not ever
going to feel better by trying to ignore
and suppress your conscience
by trying to deny
the shame and the guilt that you feel
shame and guilt are a healthy thing they
can be a healthy thing at least
because they're telling you you're going
down the wrong path
you can turn around the shame and the
guilt is not it's not the end of the
story but you
it
it's it's like how we feel pain
right you it's good that we feel pain
it's good that we feel pain because we
know that we're in danger when i put my
hand on a hot stove i'm glad that i can
feel pain because i know get my hand
away do something different
same thing here with our moral
conscience
did you like that clip good i'm glad
ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications head on
over to apple podcast but if i stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe to the michael knowles
show leave a five star review
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you